as I said before we're kind of living in
a fox America it seems to me is you know
we spend all day long talking about what
someone said at the republican national
convention when they're you know
seriously important things going on and
that's all because of kind of fox news
isn't it well i think they've clearly
helped set the agenda for lack of a
better word for a pretty large segment
of the American population so they've
been influential in that sense but it
who's to say well I mean I guess what we
are saying is that I think that if if
Fox feels that that's the right business
model it Roger Ailes wasn't the only
person who could make that so and I want
to ring back to Jeff Jarvis so we were
talking earlier about Roger Ailes and
the towering figure that he is in TV
news you said he created Donald Trump in
some ways but if you consider fox news
channel's positioning in this particular
political cycle it certainly evolved
right because they were getting pushback
certainly megyn kelly was from Donald
Trump and in one of the debates they
were putting up full screens or I should
that's the industry lingo excuse me
they're putting up fact checking
messages that that push back against a
lot of the candidates stated positions
it was no longer just a cheerleader for
the Republican Party was it yes but I
want two margaritas and I think that
that ails at murdoch's Fox News set the
tone of political discourse in this
country and that opened the door for the
insurgency of Trump taking over the
Republican Party and yes they had mixed
feelings about that but I also think
what's really going to be interesting
now is by all rumors Lachlan and his
brother have long been aiming for rails
did not get along with them want to get
rid of them they're the future of the
company the question is will they change
the tone and discourse of Fox News will
they make it more shall I say
respectable decent less divisive or will
they double down that to me it's the big
question I note that were true Barack
himself is now filled in as chairman
it's his bully pulpit in the end but at
some point if his sons James and Lachlan
have the influence to get rid of ales
what I really want to see is what
influence will they have on the channel
going forward Brian let me just
see you in 10 seconds does it matter who
wins the election for Fox News
profitability good question I don't
think so